President Biden's 2024 re-election bid
is already going off the rails and sadly
we're not just talking about a group of
school kids confusing Joe with some
simple questions Biden racking up the
lowest poll numbers of his presidency
only 37 percent of Americans approve of
the job that he's doing and that assumes
Biden is actually doing his job turns
out he only works part-time as president
most of Biden's public events happened
between 10 a.m and 4 P.M which amounts
to a 30-hour work week meanwhile his
screw-up son Hunter can't seem to get
out of the headlines this week the first
Sons attorneys met with doj prosecutors
to discuss resolving their criminal
investigation Hunters also got some
child support problems he's being forced
to appear in person in court next week
after claiming poverty relating to his
four-year-old daughter it is the case
involving the grandchild that President
Biden refuses to acknowledge
I have six grandchildren and I'm crazy
about them and I speak to them every
single day not a joke
Hunters out of wedlock daughter makes it
seven but the media would rather mock
Hunter's scandals as some right-wing
Obsession take a listen to this
but I was watching another Network the
other day Nick and I were and they were
saying oh Joe Biden he's so disconnected
from America he's so horrible he's so
this he sow that and they go to one of
the guests and say well why is he so bad
Hunter Biden's laptop and I'm sitting
here thinking are you kidding me I mean
okay if there's something on there send
him to jail
but that it were that easy
um you know will I I'll start with you
you know the the president now is 37
lowest approval rating uh after he
announces for president and the amazing
thing is this year although he says he
works between ten and four this year he
only had four events before 10 a.m and
he only had 12 so far we're almost five
months into the year and after 6 p.m and
for three months he had no weekend
events does he really want the job I was
going to say judge what a case for
reelection four more years you know
um if I might that morning Joe clip is
absolutely remarkable at least there's
an acknowledgment that Hunter Biden
exists and Morning Joe would like to
absolve itself for not covering Hunter
Biden through 2020. but what they're
willing to admit at this point is
something that the doj as well is
willing to admit which is only half the
truth that Hunter Biden is somehow
involved in some kind of tax Scandal
that there's some admission that the
laptop might be real we're getting there
let's get to the truth why there is an
obsession over Hunter Biden's laptop and
why it impunes Joe Biden because this is
a story about corruption this is a story
about potential corruption among the
Biden family that goes all the way to
the top potentially of President Biden
if Joe Scarborough is interested in the
truth and understanding why we talk
about this look into that on the laptop
all right with Julian I'll go I'll go
with with where will just went I mean
the truth is that it wasn't just about
the laptop where we are now is we have a
whistleblower who's saying that a senior
person in the IRS who's saying I want
whistleblower protection because I can
prove not because I have a political
agenda but with documents emails Etc
that this case is not being handled the
way other cases are being handled in in
the IRS meaning Hunter Biden and we also
now know that uh more Biden family
members are benefiting from the millions
that are coming from overseas
I think
the thing that we always have to point
out is that the hunter Biden story is
not really about Hunter Biden in the
sense of the national news media the
only reason this is a topic at this
table the only reason reporters cover
this some reporters the only reason
um any Americans care about it at all is
in so much as it relates to his dad and
that's what's being teased out right now
by Republicans who are investigating
this by the multiple lawsuits that are
going on I will say this about the
president's schedule
um
having worked at the White House for
four years I've seen the job up close
and personal
from a stamina perspective it's probably
the hardest job on Earth you can try and
make it easier for people you can try
and cut events cut international travel
and manage it but at the end of the day
there is no way to make this an easy job
whatever the Public's the public events
schedule is I think you said 10 10 to
four is that right that's about a fifth
probably of the president's schedule on
a weekly basis most of what he does is
not seen most of what he does is
being in meetings in The Situation Room
doing briefings phone calls so I don't
know what the White House has planned
for him is
um but it is a real challenge for
anybody to do that job I cannot imagine
how difficult it would be to do it in
your 80s but that's something they'll
have to figure out I mean I would
struggle to do it I'm less than half the
time
I'm not even 60 yet no I'm just trying
perfect
I would I was the first to tell you I
couldn't do it you know Joe Joe
Scarborough has basically said Greg that
you know we looked at this in 2020. I
mean you know was that we have absolved
him of any criminal responsibility
liability civil problems and they don't
even recognize what has happened since
then which you know was the walls
closing in on Joe and not So Much Hunter
yeah I would like to paraphrase what the
Democrats used to say no child should be
left behind unless it's a stripper baby
then all bets are off by the way happy
National creamsicle day thank you yeah I
did I would have dressed up too uh but
at least you could eat the sorbet if it
spills on you no one will notice there
you go there you go at least our
obsessions are about real things right
when Morning Joe was obsessed about
Russian collusion it never materialized
because it didn't exist by the way I
commend him on talking you didn't even
see Mika's lips move incredible and it
was their Obsession that gave them gave
Trump billions of free media free
political advertising they elected the
guy out of their obsession with ratings
so don't the reason why they say
obsession is because they're trying to
marginalize the truth like you said the
story is not about Hunter it's about the
cover-up and how it benefits the big guy
in the old days journalists would
proudly obsess over stories right a
story like that they would Dive Right In
they'd live it they'd breathe it I mean
Watergate is nothing compared to this
laptop let's be honest so a story like
this would be huge now if you're
interested in a story you're obsessed
like there's something wrong with to you
now I want to talk about his schedule
given that state of this country which
is a pretty bad State the news that the
president works a few hours a day should
trigger one thought and one thought only
God help us if he worked more right
let's get him down Envy no let's get him
down to five hours let's get him down to
four but the problem here is if he's not
working it's clear others are and he
admitted that he said when I became
president uh I I thought I'd be giving
orders now I just take them we we were
postulating that all along that he's
just a puppet so the only orders he gets
these days are take a nap and don't soil
the carpet we'll handle everything else
that's why you're seeing all this far
left stuff coming from a guy who's
basically kind of a reactionary person
about crime is now just completely
befuddled he's Elmer Fudd without the
charm
you know if he wears pants
that's a good point yes it's a very good
point he saves us but you know Jessica
they they they basically say the the
left about Hunter you know that that
were obsessed with him and we talked
about how it's really about Joe but um
that you've got Claire mccaskill now
she's a former Senator correct yeah from
Missouri she's saying that uh you know
this is just about family dysfunction
all of this and it's nothing serious
that and she goes into what about ISM
and it's as though they just feel that
you know this is like every other family
in the United States there's always one
person with a problem
well I think it's correct that most
families have someone who is an addict
in their families but obviously the
bidens are an exceptional family they're
exceptional for what they've achieved
they're exceptional for what they're
worth and the guys the president United
States of America there are other
powerful families that have a lot of
family turmoil and where kids are
trading on their father's names and
that's very very common and I don't you
know to the what about is in front I'm
sure the Claire mccaskill when she was
talking about that mentioned the trumps
and things that the Trump kids have
gotten because their last name is Trump
I don't want to minimize what the
connection to Joe Biden from Hunter
might be until we know exactly until
everything is out there but the
Republicans are doing themselves no
favors and I think that's what the
morning Joe crew is reacting to by going
on TV incessantly and talking about it
put your head down and do the work I'll
bring up the interview again Jim Comer
on with the Fox and Friends host a
couple weeks ago talking about
everything that they've got and finally
uh I think it was Brian said well what
do you got and it was then a ton of what
about us and from you know well this
could lead to this and if this and if
that the time has come to move past if
if you want to lead news Cycles with
this if you want to go about and do your
job in private and not go on national TV
all the time and boast about what you
have when you definitively have nothing
at this moment to connect Hunter Biden's
business dealings to his father
personally properly but would you not
agree
that Hunter Biden and his father have
gone together and done various things
together it's not as though uh Hunter
Biden is doing something separately and
as it relates to the Trump children
they're all in business this guy got
thrown out of the military because he
was a drug addict so what business he's
conducting in the rest of the world he's
not doing it based on his expertise and
energy well so but but but but the
question really is if the Department of
Justice takes five years of a grand jury
investigation and can't come up with an
answer as to what they're going to do
the Republicans have no choice but to
put it out in public because doj even
The Whistleblower wants to say it is not
doing what they're supposed to I think
the Whistleblower should get whatever
protections they need to be able to come
forward I am not
you draw a straight line from what
Hunter Biden was doing to his dad and
he's the big guy and he got 10 percent
and that's in a bank account that I can
see that I would say that he doesn't
deserve to be president and that we were
all taken for a big ethical ride but at
this moment in time we don't have any
evidence of that but to just to put a
ribbon on this it shouldn't be the sole
responsibility of the Republicans to
investigate the truth to Greg's point
there was a once a period in time when
the media thought it was their job to
expose the truth and not dismiss a
potential Scandal as an obsession hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else